diminuer la quantité de déchets qu'on
produit c'est une nécessité à laquelle
on devra tous adaptés mais quand on
habite dans une île le manque d'espacé
fait qu'on doit parfois trouver des
solutions plus rapidement qu'ailleurs
l'une d'elles c'est de donner une
seconde vie à certains déchets
[Musique]
mais avec madame rencontre cap trotta
d'une patate un petit peu plus loin
plutôt que nantes est une patate capoter
un poisson qui est mon père lui il
prenait des résidus d'une usine de
transformation qui est à preuve de ses
champs il aura l'assaut avec son petit
tracteur bissau trailer qui dépendent à
100 ha bro de ses tabous de travail je
te dirais que ça sattouf sefa depuis que
je te dirais que l'apache est disposé
depuis qu'il ya de l'agriculture qui
sera planté un poisson ou un crabe pour
enrichir la terre la pratique n'est pas
nouvelle et que l'agriculteur christian
poirier utilisent des carapaces de
crabes fraîchement pêchés pour
fertiliser ses champs et remplacer la
chaux qu'il doit importer à grand coût
économique et environnemental
doit se donnent rendez vous à passer le
camion qui en a la part de son de
christian des matières résiduelles et ça
pourra servir un peu mieux dans les
champs c'est sûr ça pourrait être plus
valorisées je crois que c'est un produit
qui est un noble puisque ta pauvre
valorise à sa juste valeur ces déchets
sont devenus crabe nourrit si christian
poirier applique une solution simple et
écologique à plus grande échelle que par
le passé et aux résultats
impressionnants
un phare des côtes de grès rouge des
plages de sable blanc des crabiers des
homardiers par dizaines nous sommes aux
îles de la madeleine où l'industrie de
la pêche génère en moyenne mille tonnes
de résidus marins chaque année les
carapaces de crabes de homard et
coquilles de palourdes de buxin par
milliers
[Musique]
les résidus présentement sont envoyés
aux centres de gestion des matières
résiduelles aux îles de la madeleine la
problématique c'est que on n'a pas au
site d'enfouissement la madeleine
les matières résiduelles destinés à
l'enfouissement sont exportés sur le
continent jusqu'à victoriaville dans le
centre-du-québec et 1200 kilomètres de
transport en bateau ayant camions sont
très coûteux pour la municipalité et
l'environnement en tout la gestion des
matières résiduelles représente 18% du
budget des îles soit plus du double que
sur le continent
à même de prendre le plus possible des
matières résiduelles et leur donner une
deuxième vie pour finalement à moindre
et les coûts d'exploitation pu créer un
produit à valeur ajoutée cette
contrainte insulaire a incité la
municipalité à valoriser les résidus
marins en compost depuis près de vingt
ans déjà cette valorisation est d'autant
plus d'actualité que le gouvernement
veut bannir l'enfouissement des matières
organiques au québec qui aimait près de
7 % des gaz à effet de serre annuel de
la province la problématique avec le
compost 3l la madeleine c'est qu'on a
pas beaucoup de matières carbonées qui
sont utilisés pour faire ce composteur
on doit le sud est du bois de
construction pour pouvoir le faire et ce
qui est dommage là dedans c'est que
peuvent contenir des éléments chimiques
sont néfastes pour l'épandage agricole
donc les agriculteurs du coin sans plus
raide sans les utiliser dans leurs
champs
l'autre voie de valorisation prisé par
l'industrie de la pêche et de
l'agriculture et l'épandage de carapace
concassés en guise d'engrais et de chaux
les rebuts des usines de transformation
devienne la matière première des
agriculteurs grâce à un cycle plus court
et plus économique que le compost c'est
ce qu'on appelle l'économie circulaire
la peau de gorzow à ça si tu veux à
comparer à la chaux qui va traverser le
golf au complet il ya deux provinces
pour promener ici je pense que cela
apportera des roses dépenses pour les
producteurs agricoles donc le
gouvernement et subventionnant les coûts
de transport pour que la shoah
reviennent aux producteurs un coût égal
pour tout le monde à la grandeur du
québec
christian poirier le premier agriculteur
a participé aux essais du centre de
recherche sur les milieux insulaires et
maritime le serbe hymne il cultive
principalement des pommes de terre puis
du navet et des 40
oui bon ça c'est l'autre
autant de bernis c'est quasiment rendu
aux poussières attentes dachau c'est
super de boer
[Musique]
ports la journée commence tôt certains
crabiers sont en mer depuis quelques
jours déjà celle usines de
transformation qui dicte les aires de
départ et d'arrivée de chaque bateau
pour qu'ils s'arriment à la cadence de
la transformation
[Musique]
quelques heures à peine après les
premiers débarquement de crabe des
neiges les premiers résidus sortent de
l'usiné
du moment s'asseoir de lusine faut que
je les mettre au chant c'est vraiment la
fraîcheur si tu veux pas avoir de
programme le tour de ça tous les soirs
du mouvement 72e c'est ce que ça prend
un peu de temps on dirait à peu près à
environ une heure pour étendre quoi
est-ce que c'est qu'ils voient que votre
interviennent dans la journée
attendu une journée ou du genre à
laisser solo dans les temps 2 j'aurais
eu départ
s'arrêter normal si
l'agriculteur préfère les résidus cuit
exempt de chair pour minimiser les
odeurs parce qu aux îles les maisons
sont proches des zones agricoles
l'autorisation d'épandage doit
d'ailleurs être octroyée par le
ministère de l'environnement et de la
lutte contre les changements climatiques
du québec
au niveau des organes de l'installer
caractérise déjà comme le dal a pu la
plus désagréable on est donc il ya
beaucoup de
réglementation à propos de ça
dissident se défend ici on a fait des
essais avec des coquilles de panneaux
employés on va passer plus de couvrir le
champ safak impression m'arrive pas de
l'épandage de crack hui de crabes comme
un cavalier boyer comment directement
comment la sortie usine ç'a donné des
bons résultats le but est cette sauce
état de monter le péage beaucoup parce
que fois que visa et enfin au moins de
ces cinq à preuve ses preuves de cette
parce qu'ici je cultive du bourdon s'en
prenait à un ps qui est à presque nue
seul hic aucune le pas lourd ça a très
bien marché
c'est ça sans rien
on a répandu au cou la saison environ
100 tonnes sur les méthodes qui sont
générés par les usines
il reste encore neuf cents tonnes de
résidus valorisables le ser mime s'est
donc doté d'une nouvelle usine pour
valoriser la totalité si carapace
et scientifique multiplient les tests
comme ceux du broyage lanuf acteurs sont
intéressants pour pouvoir agir comme
chaud on met à mal de la composition
chimique de la matière en tant que tels
que lucas bonne de calcium les quais de
palourdes sont composés à peu près de 90
à 95% de carbonate de calcium donc le
potentiel est très bon il ya aussi la
granulométrique plus de granulométrie et
fine plus qu'à watts efficaces en duo
chant
[Musique]
ça c'est le terrain pas ses craintes et
les nuits je pense sa fortune et des
variétés qui exploite
christian poirier va aussi dépendre
d'autres résidus au début de l'automne
en même temps que la reprise de la pêche
au crabe commun
la première matinée de cette filiale
c'est que les périodes de pêche et les
périodes d'épandage se croisent fois
100% une période de pêche où les
promeneurs je n'ai pas possible donc
n'est pas possible de passer toutes les
quantités qui sont générés par les
industries par contre on va travailler
dans une prochaine phase assez de faire
un engrais qui vont peut conserver qui
pourra à ce moment là être valorisée à
l'année longue
et si comme on peut le constater le
voisin lui l'ami du fumier de ce sont
les produits du fond qui moi en même
temps ma un remy du crabes du mo bosse
et on peut voir la différence
dfa et comment répondre au ccdh harvard
a pilot moss et c'est tout à fait
d'accord il assoit son épandage de
fumier luton qui m'ont aussi comme en
même temps la même semaine qui s y sont
on peut voir la grosse émotion on n'a
pas de capteur de rendement temps
tellement on a pu apercevoir à l'est et
au nombre de balles qui ont été faites
lors des récoltes que lorsqu'il y avait
des amendements qui étaient ajoutés à la
terre pour les besoins des plans les
rangs de l'intérieur
en plus d'améliorer ses rendements
christian poirier a drastiquement
diminué sa consommation d'engrais
chimiques et le sapin décoré d'épitaphe
a surtout le bord parce que le bon il
est beaucoup moins tendre dans les sols
ou z le bon c'est un élément qui est
présent dans les résidus de crise c'est
partir se réchauffe au curieux corrigera
la plantation des règles mais sinon
l'algérie du mans consommation d'engrais
l'aude abou show 100% comme il faut et
plus
selon moi c'est que du positif c'est
vraiment au point de vue de
l'environnement que ces mots que les
groupes c'est un investissement à long
terme au sein de même que grosso la
santé des sols c'est primordial nous dit
tout le temps que la salle c'est comme
un conte de casse si tu files des
retraites et qu'il fallut de récolter
les récoltes et puis qui donne rien aux
soldes un moment donné sont tombés dans
le groupe
[Musique]